salut la team mantallot souvent dans les
commentaires vous me demandez si j'ai
des trucs pour la motivation les choses
comme ça j'avais fait une vidéo sur la
procrastination je vous la met ici dans
la fiche mais sachez que le problème de
motivation c'est bien souvent d'un
problème de stratégie c'est parce que
t'as pas ta stratégie que t'as pas la
bonne motivation pour avancer
aujourd'hui je vous présente un livre
qui a été important pour moi toute ma
vie c'est un livre de meta métaphore qui
a été écrit par un général chinois il ya
2500 ans
c'est un texte légendaire on lui
attribue on n'est pas sûr et certain
mais on lui attribue c'est l'art de la
guerre de sun tzu à la base l'art de la
guerre c'est un traité militaire je vous
dis pas de faire la guerre je dis pas de
penser comme un militaire en tout cas
pas pour être offensif pour agresser les
autres par contre toute ma vie j'ai
appliqué les conseils de l'art de la
guerre contre moi même ou avec moi même
dans un pub stratégie pour lancer le
mental vlog le défi d'une vidéo par jour
j'ai abordé le projet comme un combat
faire un défi de mer c'est un combat et
j'ai appliqué à ce combat toutes les
stratégies que j'ai pu y apprendre
il existe plein plein plein plein plein
de versions en fait de ce texte de 1500
ans et libre de droit je vais vous
mettre un lien dans la description de
toutes les versions vous pouvez trouver
il ya des versions qui sont commentées
très honnêtement c'est pas mon kiff
peut-être ce sera bien pour vous mais
c'est pas mon kiff d'avoir les
commentaires de quelqu'un j'ai préféré
avoir ma propre opinion ma propre
résonance mais un peu comme dans les
livres genre le code du ninja ou c'est
le genre de choses on y retire une
interprétation personnelle qui est
intéressant qui peut évoluer dans le
temps de ma version préférée c'est celle
ci parce que elle est illustrée en
termes de graphiques et de schémas et ça
on le sait les graphiques et les schémas
ça me parle pour que vous puissiez bien
comprendre tout l'intérêt de ça et
pourquoi cet ouvrage est si important
pour moi je lis un extrême est vraiment
au hasard garder je fais comme ça stop
stop
bon d'accord c'est pas un grand extrait
je refais et stop stop alors c'est ce
qu'on a en prenant des dispositions
tactiques le summum et de les dissimuler
si vous dissimuler vos dispositions vous
serez à l'abri des espions les plus
subtiles et des machinations des esprits
les plus rusés
rares sont ceux qui arrivent à
comprendre comment la victoire peut être
accompli à partir de la tactique même de
l'ennemi alors ça dans un projet quel
qu'il soit je la clique à chaque fois
c'est à dire que j'essaie de faire mes
projets en silence comme on dit bien il
ya un truc qui tournait avant sur
facebook avec ça s'était faite vos
projets en silence la réussite se
chargera du bruit mais il ya un peu de
l'idée de cet adage dedans c'est à dire
si vous faites une préparation minutes
dieuze mais sans la dévoiler déjà vous
allez créer la surprise et ça c'est
intéressant et en faisant ce travail là
par contre vous allez étudier toute la
stratégie des autres personnes dans le
même domaine pour vous en inspirer pour
mieux la comprendre pour comprendre
qu'est ce qui marche et qu'est ce qui ne
marche pas en clair tout le gros boulot
se fait en coulisse et doit être
invisible je voulais aussi celui qui a
coté tous peuvent voir les tactiques par
lesquels je compte y est mais ce que nul
ne peut voir c'est la stratégie dont
émane de la victoire ne reproduisait pas
les tactiques qui vous ont assuré une
victoire mais laissez vos méthodes
s'adapter à l'infinie variété de
circonstance
en clair il faut se réinventer en
permanence faut toujours trouver de
nouvelles idées
quand je vous explique l autre genre que
j'allais pas refaire exactement le même
défi l'année prochaine parce que sinon
ça n'aura plus de sens et c'est ça c'est
exactement l'application de cette phrase
c'est à dire que c'est pas parce que un
truc avait été coulé à fonctionner un
certain temps qui va toujours fonctionné
il faut chercher à se réinventer en
permanence parce que tout change autour
de nous en permanence pourrait vous
parler de ce bouquin durant des heures
vous avez eu que c'est un truc vraiment
qui me passionne j'espère que vous aurez
donné envie de le lire d'une manière ou
d'une autre il existe dans toutes les
médiathèques et toutes les bibliothèques
si vous n'avez pas envie de l'acheter
c'est facile de se le procurer d'une
manière ou d'une autre qu'un bête vous
savez quoi je vous en offrir un et ça
c'était pas prévu on va faire un
concours de le faire par tirage au sort
comme ça tout le monde pourra participer
si je le fais par mail il n'ya pas avoir
de réseau social ou quoi envoyer moi
juste un mail avec votre nom votre
prénom et votre adresse pour que je
puisse l'envoyer à on va dire concours @
fabien olicard point fr ils ont lundi je
suis un tirage au sort et je commande un
livre sur internet et je vous le fais
envoyé à vous directement
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu
et que vous pourrez laisser un petit
pouce en l'air très important pour le
faire savoir n'oubliez pas également de
vous abonner avant de partir puisque le
mental boxe et une vidéo par jour
pendant un an donc rendez vous demain à
11 heures à 11 heures je serais vous je
serai là vraiment à 11 heures demain
parce qu'il ya un truc qui va aller très
vite demain 11
donc rendez vous demain à 11h ciao